this new high-end technology will
enlighten the skin and give you the
power of three dragons it's like it's a
massager you know how's it going I'm
Matt what up everybody I'm Irish and
today we're gonna be looking at a couple
beauty products and figuring out what
they are how much they cost and what
they really do let's go whoa
my first instinct is this is looking
like roll-on deodorant kind of that's a
lot better than what I thought I thought
it was gonna be like a tongue scraper
it's also looking like a highlighter
like you could pop that blue car off at
the bottom and then highlight all your
social studies homework thinking about
price it doesn't look like a expensive
item to me it kind of looks like
something you'd have in your bathroom
maybe next to the mouthwash yeah
hang it up next to the razor alright so
first of all I think this product is
called the flower roller pretty
confident on that I'm gonna say it is a
Yoda Rijn stick slash thermometer and
I'm gonna say it cost 3195 what do you
think in Irish
if we're giving this a title I'm gonna
say that it is called the rolling
applicator I believe you put moisturizer
on that and then drill it into your
cheeks and this should not be more than
$14.99 it's the Patrick Bateman thing
right just you know the classy everyday
role model Patrick Bateman zero points
on the board baby oh wow this is the
brother or sister of the ice roller it
doesn't like it's made by the same
company the handle looks super similar
it looks like that's probably gonna be
in the same price range I don't know if
it's a part of the construction of it
but it looks like there's a button on
this thing all right I think I'm ready I
am good too this is called the rolling
exfoliator and basically what you do is
you push that little button and you put
it like on your nose and that charcoal
looking thing rubs away all your
blackheads and stuff I think they're
pricing these around 75 bucks I think
this product is called the
i blaster and i think this is not a skin
thing really it's more of a makeup thing
almost like a painter you're gonna rub
that onto your palate and then put it
over your eyes
this goes for 40 flat I knew it we
didn't know it I had if I was always in
the same vein all right I'm gonna step
my game up this looks familiar I feel
like I've seen these in like cat videos
when you rub it on their face I do
believe you're probably onto something
with the face and maybe massaging also
how do you even hold it all right this
this product is called the Tingler and
you're going to want to get these points
you know it's to like roll out your
muscle and this goes for 35 this bad boy
is a floral roller you hold it at your
face like this and then push it in and
it opens up and relaxes your cheeks
29.99 I'm not doing too good here
Wow first thing I'm thinking is like a
cap for your lipstick so it doesn't dry
out
next thing I'm thinking is adult
pacifiers this looks like some a beauty
product that pissed me off like a couple
years ago and so I think I might know
what this is this also looks like I
could be a monopoly piece or a tiny red
top hat for my pet rat this is what's
called a lip plumper do you put it over
your mouth like that and then you like
suck it into your face and it makes your
lips get all big I'm almost certain my
sister has one of these and I've made it
and I pretty sure it ran it runs about
24 95 if that's true that's wild you can
just buy a mini M&Ms bottle and do that
right I'm gonna stick with my first
thought was to cover for lipstick I
think you're pretty cheap and go for
probably like twelve dollars and they're
called the sweet sweet little holders
[Music]
all right let's see this next product
I'm ready
[Music]
oh well we got here a pogo stick
jackhammer Irish I'm stumped um you are
crushing me and it seems like maybe a
health product because nurse Jamie
wouldn't just call herself a nurse all
right it looks super sexual man or just
like super medical
the second I saw this I was like oh I UD
I think it's called the pressure 5000
and you like work it into muscle areas
this is a $55 I'm gonna say that this is
a hair vacuum you hold it like this so
now the sticks pointing up at you you
put it into your nasal cavity and you
push on the little buttons and it'll
suck the hairs out this is a high grade
technology we're talking about here it's
gonna run you 75 Wow oh my god I gotta
say I love the descriptions they use for
products it'll be like a massager and
they'll be like this new high-end
technology will enlighten the skin and
give you the power of three dragons it's
like it's a massager you know it does
what it does it massages
[Music]
oh don't even you know I don't even got
a guess I'm ready to so this is the
Beautyblender and essentially after
you've applied your foundation your
highlight and then whatever the shadow
is called you take the pointy part and
you massage it in so that you blend it
does $20 package I mostly agree with
Irish I've seen these before and I do
think they're used for concealer and
foundation to blend it in yes there's a
pack of them I think they go for
probably like eighteen fifty and yeah
they're used to mix it all together to
blend your beauty as it were
[Music]
what the hell so this is a Pokemon this
typically will come with a play-doh set
and you Jam him on top of the play-doh
and then all the play-doh seeps out if
we weren't reviewing beauty products I
would think this is a gardening tool to
be honest but since it is a beauty
product I really have no clue what this
could do there's like a little slits in
it for maybe like for what water to seep
out like why so I think that this piece
is an attachment to a blow dryer you
know when you want air to blast out of a
hand at your favorite that's what it is
it's called the hand dryer and it goes
for $32 price I don't know how I'm gonna
top that you buy this with your pack of
makeup brushes and what you do is you
Jam them into the bottom and you let
water run through so that you wash it
and I believe it's called the brush
detoxifier and these bad boys are $7.99
well done four to five this is neck and
neck this is neck and neck
[Music]
hey this isn't here ranma's roller all
right this is granite for some reason
this is for the the wealthy and it's got
gold on it it's beautiful
so yeah it's looking like another one of
those rolling products I don't think you
put something on it because it would
probably just wash off that marble right
away I'm gonna say it's the marble
double sided universal beauty trend
roller and this goes for 112 sure I'm
gonna say this is called a face roller
and I'm almost certain I've seen this
and I think it's a way to disperse the
cream the product into this skin like
deep into the pores how much think this
goes for but I'm gonna keep it simple
$14.99 Wow for marble yeah I think it's
fake great game iris you bested me solid
it was a solid game I I lucked out with
the lip plumper because if you take away
those three points I think you win the
game honestly what I did learn about is
that you know there are a ton of
products when it comes down to it my
products are a toothbrush toothpaste
soap really at the end of the day there
aren't that many intricate products that
I use so either a I got to step up my
skincare game or be it's over - it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]